what's going on there citizens of the
reject nation we're gonna watch cobra
kai season five
episode six today after that brilliant
episode of episode five andrew how you
doing i'm doing fine craig how are you
good good good thank you for asking john
good good good thank you for asking
thank you for asking you for asking and
uh andrew grossi's shirts hey he's
selling them on the corner of waneka and
oxnard 20 bones uh guys leave a like
that'd be very much appreciated also
subscribe and click that notification
bell to get notified when our reaction
for the next episode is up here on the
channel
yeah fullness watch along with our
patreon and uh the prep team thank you
for watching what are we doing
[Music]
who are you bringing in you look like a
guy from phantasm
[Music]
multiple people new senseis
[Music]
eye patch guy
are these the kids he
trained with hillary swing
i'm rooting for it man
holy crap wow i'm offering you full
autonomy to test my students your way i
did not get on the plane for money
fifty
50
is just a number
what i'm offering you
is legacy
and you think your american students are
up to the task
i do
we shall feel
[Music]
here we go
let's whip some ass with that braid did
you get a real rejects private plane
i never understood why mr miyagi walked
away from a fight but i understand it
now
it's not our job to fight the monsters
of the world
not anymore
oh daniel caruso putting on the glasses
just like in karate kid
that's funny hiding the black guy just
like in the first movie when i get out
of here i'll take care of the other you
don't care about what happened to mr
russo he was a means to an end
is that what i am of course not
you and i are the only ones who can
trust each other of course
but he'll slip
and that'll be the opening that we need
can you handle that
yes sensei and where's that shank i
asked you for
oh she joined topanga karate
we're thrilled to be part of the cobra
kai family thank you sensei rosenthal
you'll be given a new sensei
you're replacing me terry
this wasn't the deal we made it shabbat
services
integrity sensei rosenthal
if you want to be taught by the best of
the best
step up and take a ghee from sensei
odell
if you want to quit
then at least take a complimentary
thermos
it's poison all around the rim
your champion stays here
before
i need to see who the best fighters are
in this dojo
you will help me test them
this is crazy jesus
it's live it's happening right now
perfect i'm going to go down there and
beat his ponytail ass you can't just
march down there like a one-man army
well i can't please say something to you
amanda's son is right
one-man army not good thank you
what do you think about that old man be
the good soldier
i think that's a fine
one thing that really surprised me was
how easy it was to get along with all
the other men
not all prisoners your age have the same
experience their
usually easy targets well i made a
stronger stuff you could throw me right
through a window and
i wouldn't even get a scratch
[Laughter]
you're not just sweet talking me to get
you a good recommendation are you
oh of course not i just find these
sessions so very helpful show me knife
strike palm strike back face five up
five down
cheese
sinister ass music
fine
but you'll break your hand if you hit
someone like that you know what i'm
doing
then hit me
wrong
[Music]
you didn't have to come i can handle
this myself not likely silva very
dangerous but i'm ready for him this
time and i can be dangerous too
this is so cool
did he mention how i kicked his ass back
in high school
i've robbed him while he was on date
oh yeah i pushed him down a cliff i
fight him to death oh yeah whether you
ghost or something
you know a few months ago i saw him take
on an entire hockey team five on one he
beat them all i saw him save young girl
from typhoon
what are you doing one of my students is
in there not here for student if a
server must wait for right time
i finally
i love them together man they're so good
[Music]
come on man you gotta be a little more
patient
you think this is my first day i know
the difference between a breakthrough
and saying what i wanna hear
if you want to get out early you really
need to think about why you're here in
the first place he's framed
there's also that bigger picture
pick this up
stop her
use any means necessary
you have one minute he's gotta get
intimidating an anime
voice your face
you do not go easy
or is this what it means in america to
be a champion
again
just punch her in the face
damn this is day one
[Music]
determination
that is the way of the fist
nothing less remember that you come to
our country with your violence
we have enough problems here huh
i'm here to help
i believe that deep down
you're a good man
i don't believe that you were always as
violent a person
oh
oh damn he's going through some real
therapy who was she
the love of my life but her death
allowed me to do what i had to do
whatever it took to save yourself
geez
after vietnam you became a sensei
taught kids how to fight i taught them
to be strong to take the anger they feel
and turn it into power
what an interesting choice of words
you feel angry john
at who the people that put me in this
cage but you did this to yourself
i did nothing wrong
oh so you don't feel any regret
what exactly am i supposed to feel
regret
for the people you've heard
damn
oh my god that's crazy i was trying to
make my students tough
you wanted them all to be like you it's
all right
less so when it moves but yeah i know
you can be better than the person you've
become
he's locked inside you
somewhere deep
you just have to find them
a lot of these like
psychological subconscious confrontation
what do you want with sensei silver we
have a message
i'm gonna beat his ass uh-huh
i don't think you can beat me oh yeah
true yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's a friggin g
this is awesome music
yeah
yeah
the team up we didn't know we needed but
wanted you must be chosen toguchi far
from your pathetic little island aren't
you and i'm surprised to see daniel
larusso has healed from his injury so
quickly
what the hell about daniel
russo we're not gonna let you take over
the valley
we already did
tournament turn up and we'll settle this
the old way
you beat me on the mat
but i only lose if i give up
miss lee
she'll set you up with a pass in case
you want to train after hours oh
i definitely will
the cycle repeats
she failed the test she ran away
the test was not for her it was for you
hmm i wanted to see how much strength
you had in your heart
to accomplish what you need to do and
what's that
something greater
than you could ever imagine is there
like a fight club plan happening here
what's going on
underground karate
mr miyagi avoided a fight whenever
possible but he also fought when he had
to
and if you were here right now
i think you would tell dad that
this is a fight we can't walk away from
it's good speech samantha get mike
barnes out yeah
they need hillary swank
hey sensei no oh i'm here for my jello
cup today
ears full of [ __ ] old man
let me clean them out for you
how the hell is this bag of bones in
here for assault
find out yeah
look around find out know me very well
yeah
have you got a ship
oh my god cobra kai starts with it here
king of the high school
he's going to be the kingpin of the
prison you're going to give me your joe
you got a problem with that
no i can't hear you
no
since
that was awesome
what are we doing here i thought we were
heading home
uh we just have to make a quick stop
come on all the students are gonna be
around ready to be trained still all
have breadsticks yes
[Music]
oh
standing up to terry silver
it's the right thing to do every time i
try to fight for what's right
somebody gets hurt i can't fail these
kids again
you didn't fail me
i mean i should have listened to you
about cobra kai
but i didn't understand until i started
mentoring someone myself
we need to stop kobra kai
but we can't do it without you
sensei
[Music]
so what do you say dad
will you fight
[Music]
yeah this show's so good
on your left
danny
this is the one i cried the most during
yeah it's funny you said each one's
gotten you like a little misty-eyed but
yeah this one did it like
i love that you kind of transition that
out of two stories you get this like
intense moment of like
really gratifying catharsis with crease
but you also see almost in a way that
it's not the same as what like uh miguel
and robbie had to go through but you
know it's that that fight that leads to
dislodging something within you that
leads to some kind of
you know
emotional leap and then to transition
from there back into the kind of the
flip of the situation where it's about
heartening and and enlivening somebody
and you know re kind of calibrate
reorienting them to the real purpose of
the fight or the situation at hand like
yeah i thought they earned really nicely
the developments of this episode and to
finally be here in episode six the very
end of episode six and to have at least
the miyagi eagle whatever it's going to
be called now kind of back into
formation it feels like an appropriate
amount of time i haven't sit here i
haven't been sitting here being like
when's it going to happen
but now that it has happened it does
feel
like the debate
has you know been satisfied and and it
yeah just feels like kind of the right
time so i thought they did a really nice
job
with this one especially because this is
like the heaviest episode and again you
pointed out like
continuing the use of that motif of you
know these these personified
traumas represented by the various
important people in in somebody's life
like i love the stuff they did with
crease
and uh yeah what did you guys think
uh all right really quick i'll just do
the easter eggs and references before i
forget them uh the first one was with
daniel where he has the black guy and
he's putting on the sunglasses uh that
happened in the first cry-kid film after
the beach scene where he meets ali
johnny gives him a black guy he puts on
his sunglasses and his mother's asking
him why he's wearing the sunglasses
that's reference to that we get the uh
sentence say to anyone who suffers from
domestic violence
okay that's a reference to that as well
uh we also get to make a really dark
character
yeah we we got several mentions but i'm
also going to mention it again uh the uh
they said she was the granddaughter
right of master kim sung young yeah okay
the master uh the granddaughter of
master kim sung young who we obviously
know is the uh sensei who trained john
crease and uh
terry silver we also got uh the line
from
uh chosen where he said uh too much
advantage there dojo that was a line
spoken by mr miyagi and the first karate
kid when chris uh says uh when they
offered him a challenge and his dojo
said too much advantage your dojo
so there was a reference to that line we
also see the pieces of paper that says
paint the house that was when mr miyagi
went fishing and daniel had to do the
chores while he was still learning wax
on wax off and all that stuff and we
also got the picture of mr miyagi's wife
which was from the first film uh where
mr miyagi was uh drunk and a very
depressed state of mind and we saw that
picture those are all my easter eggs and
references in regards to this uh this
episode rather i agree with john this
was definitely the heaviest uh i wasn't
just misty-eyed unless i was
i was full-on crying especially at the
end there was
you know really amazes me we're in
season five now and the level of quality
that this show still holds it's really
impressive because a lot of times shows
when they get i mean it's just
impressive just to get to season five if
you're a show
you know you you definitely give credit
to a show if they're able to last that
long but to still have this level
of uh
as good as this is it's it's just it's
really impressive when you really think
about it but
getting back into what i mentioned in
the last episode with daniel how broken
he is i like that they didn't just go
away from that and say oh yeah he healed
he's good he's ready to go again i'm
glad that they touched upon like no he's
not ready he's like he's really broken
and even like just talking to him when
doing that again i just love how earned
it is because how satisfying it was and
emotional was at the end for all the
students to come together for amanda to
tell the story about mr miyagi about the
night before they got married
and then with the
chosen and johnny saying we're here by
your side and with all the students like
that is such a more emotionally
satisfying payoff to daniel like coming
back
you know to where he needs to be
emotionally spiritually mentally than if
at you know he's just physically healed
oh he's back okay cool like that that
would have been the easy way out for the
writers but this is such a smarter more
fascinating way and i'm so glad they
went this route it was just so
beautifully done and again
i i mean i was really i truly was
bawling my eyes out it was so beautiful
so wonderfully done and again the
on-screen chemistry and interactions
between daniel and amanda fantastic i
also love too the stuff we got with
crease that john mentioned earlier
the visual psychology that they were
showing all the different characters and
that was so cool how they had a young
johnny was not expecting that was really
very fascinating to watch but seeing his
wife seeing the the captain from uh the
season three the flashbacks where we got
in vietnam uh who broke the news that
johnny's uh wife or soon uh fiance or
girlfriend was uh killed in the accident
and you know just seeing all this drama
because we got kind of a little bit of a
glimpse of this in the end of season
four where you know chris had that
reflective moment that we saw in season
four so you know getting really into the
psychology of john crease i thought was
really interesting and really very
satisfying to watch and made for good
storytelling and i thought that was a
wise decision and i really like that
actress that they have that's playing
the granddaughter of uh master kim sung
young she's
really i mean
craig laid it out she's really hot but
she's also really
she's really intimidating i like how hot
she is yeah she's very intimidating too
like
like you know just looking at her from
an outside perspective like yeah she's a
good looking woman but then when you
actually see her her acting prowess and
like the uh the way she presents herself
like even as a sensei like she's really
scary but in in a very satisfying way
and she i love the way she trains like i
mean and seeing the difference in
training from like miyagi doe eagle fang
and even terry silver and john crease to
the way master kim sung young i find
that so fascinating it just expands the
lore of cobra kai and karate kid
it does expand the lord of course karate
kid that's a good point
salt stuff thanks
alright guys
be sure to subscribe and click that bell
uh
yeah
okay
watch me pull out some new points
[ __ ] i must blow your mind
it's to come up with references
i'm going to say things you guys haven't
said okay yeah watch
hillary swank
i think uh
i think what makes this season um and
this episode in particular so
effective is
how
there's almost this like rehabilitation
quality
to it you know obviously like something
more direct is with chris
who wouldn't heal from one therapy
session all right like who you need like
you need like intensive therapy and this
was the most overt they've ever been of
like there's actually a good guy just
like way deep down there that's just a
lot of crap piled on top of him
but there is someone with a more humane
quality there and i like the flip
that
he actually goes against every like you
seem like you're a trajectory where he's
going to just like all right you know
what i'm going to do the healing and the
good work and stuff then he ends up
becoming like on his way to becoming
kingpin of the prison
so i thought that was like a nice flip
because it it manages to both hit you
with that feeling of oh
and also hell yeah like it's kind of a
weird thing as an audience member to put
you in of having for me at least two
different feelings of because at the end
of the day it is sort of him just
accepting who he is and then of course
with danny's uh like rehabilitation
where there is almost
this uh what is the term again i'm
totally blind what's the term when like
someone we need to confront a family
member
intervention it almost is like an
intervention like quality with
amanda coming to terms with
understanding more and there's this
acceptance and resolution theme that has
been
spread throughout this whole season
uh already and then even with amanda
coming to acceptance and samantha coming
to acceptance with this whole situation
uh you see it with johnny and chosen and
then with the students and like having
robbie have his scene with danny just
waiting in the corner off to the side of
like this is my moment to enter he's
going to say a thing then i'm going to
walk in front
like they they like the way they shot
that because there was this almost
dreamlike
quality to it because it wasn't a dream
but they they because of the power of
filmmaking i buy like little moments
like that like sure he's just there
he's there to show up at the right the
right line enter frame and with uh and
then with samantha there each coming to
terms with it and i like how it's this
unity that forms to uplift daniel and to
say no we are all on the the same page
and this is more important than we got
to win some tournaments we got to beat
some guy like this is so much more
personal like it felt that way from the
they managed to
make a plot line that could feel
repetitive feel more personal than it
has been in a while
because it's always there's always been
personal qualities entangled within
but for the main two to go toe-to-toe
with each other daniel versus terry
specifically
how they rung that out of the last
episode with you know bringing back
jessica andrews and then now
complimenting it here
i think there's like the almost a dark
knight rises quote
of a man who is like was on a fight and
then is now beaten and broken and has
lost all faith and then
finds his faith again but it's through a
sense of uh community
you know and i i think that is a very
strong
quote like again it's the the heart of
this show is is so strong
and
the biggest
just his biggest asset
is is the heart
and
you know seeing like little things that
i did not i remember there was like a
trailer that came out i didn't i didn't
watch it but there was i saw the
thumbnails
of of uh chosen and johnny standing side
by side
and there is something so rewarding
about watching them together because did
they have scenes together they didn't
have scenes together at all in season uh
uh season three season three now because
you know
daniel went to okinawa and johnny was
still in the valley yeah exactly that he
just shows up at the end of the last
season yeah
um
so yeah to have to see them have scenes
together and
there was something so beautiful about
the way they talked about their
antagonistic relationship with playing
tops with each other
and then it becomes about
why daniel's so inspirational and why
he's so great
and for a season that hasn't painted him
in quite the best light
it
it was neat to bring it back to oh yeah
you know he really is a great guy yeah
he really is an inspiring human being
who just went kind of lost his own path
and lost his own light
and
even the fact that he gave up this goal
of defeating terry silver
stems from a beautiful sacrifice which
is to preserve his family like even that
choice is stemmed in an act of love
so it reminded you like oh yeah this is
a great person
and for his former enemies to be bonding
over
that person who influenced them that
much they're
it it adds more strength to the
character of daniel
and so i thought like there was this
really again like the the feeling i got
was like a strong rehabilitation quality
uh throughout so yeah it's a really
really good episode that's something mr
miyagi would be so proud of
i really was expecting though
obviously kidding mike barnes to come in
and say but i broke his bonsai tree yeah
the the the gang of uh senseis is a bit
is a bit anime
is that the one thing i'm like i this
could get a little too broad if they
don't flesh it a little bit more well
that lead actor actress is so uh is so
good yeah it sells it yeah like the the
other guy who i'm sure was hired mainly
for his great martial arts skills more
than his it's his voice okay it was like
this is you said anime or i thought of
like every time in a jackie chan movie
like one of the stunt team gets one line
and it always sounds kind of like that
yeah
yeah i'm putting on a voice
i'm a bad guy i'm gonna fight tough
fighter warrior
yeah my whole life i've been training
yeah it doesn't it wasn't very good but
uh no it's it's ridiculous and i think
every season has something that goes
that pushes the envelope you gotta i
think that's the beauty of what cobra
kai does
is it's
it has to
it has to get to the line
like just gets close enough to the line
of ridiculousness but don't cross it
yeah and like that's the beautiful line
that they can ride a lot of the time
is
just get right up there but just don't
go over it yeah
and uh and i think you know yeah this
team of like i guess got the best
assassins in the world and then like
whatever this
freaking tyler durden plan is that uh
that terry silver has like
because it's not because only the
seasons build up to like we gotta have a
tournament i mean i know season three
didn't right uh that didn't build up to
a tournament even though it did end with
we're gonna fight at the tournament
it this does not have a clear direction
of what the showdown is supposed to be
and there's something that feels more
i don't know i'm not sure what the right
word is or something that feels
it allows you to just kind of stay with
the emotions of the characters instead
of just advancing the plot because
whenever terry shows up it is more
menacing because you don't quite know
what his
ultimate plan is other than just like
corporate cobra kai global domination
yeah well yeah
it it it adds a level of like oh damn i
had the word now it's gone but yeah it
it gives it this quality where you don't
know exactly where it's heading so it
feels like any number of things could
happen and i think that is important for
a season like this when you do have so
many to look back at and go oh yeah you
just ended the tournament yeah yeah yeah
i'm also really looking forward to in
these last four episodes just seeing
like the main core of kids like really
get their uh their moments now to shine
because really through the first six
episodes we've gotten glimpse of them at
the water park a few scenes here and
there i mean samantha's had her her
moments uh miguel and robbie but like
dimitri hawk and all the kenny and a lot
of other characters they've really been
more on the sidelines like haven't
really been
too much of the focus of these episodes
so i'm really you know really fascinated
really interested to see these last four
episodes how they really flesh out more
of those characters and we get back into
those storylines because the first six
have been great no complaints from me
but i'm just really i'm curious to see
how they insert those characters now and
and just let them you know flesh out
those characters even more so and you
know going from there i'm really curious
and fascinated to see just worried for
devon i mean not that i don't
i like those characters i i think part
of what's made every episode so strong
is that they've only chosen to really
focus on a few though yeah no for sure
as opposed to we got
like a cast of 40 people yeah i totally
i totally agree with you but i think
like in the first four seasons they've
done a good job while i agree with you
they've done a lot of the job definitely
been pushed to the background yeah no
but just with they can handle an
ensemble
ensemble
and then even getting the i think what
the show does really well then we should
definitely uh i think the show does
really well is like the patience of
waiting to learn more about someone's
backstory like we've learned more about
amanda than ever yeah and um you know
like that mem learning that memory is
really sweet but yeah and and i think uh
and then there's also the taurean devin
devin's the asian girl right yeah her
mother
her mother with cancer yeah yeah yeah
they both
they both
yeah uh devon is a very
fascinating character to watch too
that uh
strange sense of determination and
resilience
and so which would both great for a
cobra guy
well yeah and now tori can see from the
outside
she can have her own robbie and kenny
moment yeah that's what they do they all
get replaced
all right guys well thanks for being
here
keep a lookout for our next reaction and
let's end this with a patron
eric horstmann we have looked up your
name on urban dictionary yeah the man
with the real rejects tattoo john
tell him what his name means eric is a
person who is on a quest to get chicken
wings but he always runs into obstacles
that prevent him from obtaining
obtaining his desire eric
you're in atlanta there's gotta be some
good chicken wings around i don't i
refuse to believe that you can't find
any well he's a vegan he can't eat
chicken wings we could eat he could eat
jackfruit chicken wings those don't
taste they don't taste the same awful
and they just remind you of what rubbery
chicken wings taste like but but guess
what else eric does all right this makes
up for it entirely eric rides baby
dinosaurs
with baby
jesus now that
is about the coolest thing i could
imagine what a lot of people don't
realize is eric horstmann was really the
person responsible for carrying baby
jesus to the manger where the three
kings greeted him with gifts he was the
donkey he rode
baby jesus
on a with with a dinosaur
he wrote him on a dinosaur with baby
jesus on his suffocated baby jesus
all the way
to that that little that little stack of
hay just looking for some chicken wing
and
he just wanted some food and then three
people showed up gifting this baby and
now one of them had chicken one chicken
wing now one had chicken wings foreign
among them a bunch of [ __ ] those
kings were yeah
why why we sing about them when we
should be singing about eric in church
he got so disillusioned by it all and
dehydrated from the desert walk that
when the drummer boy came by he saw a
chicken
and he ate that drummer boy that's right
man and from that day forward eric vowed
never to eat meat again
because yeah children could get hurt
it's a real thing
it's good eric this is a sacrifice
that's very noble stop eating children
man that's the lesson of the story
thank you
[Music]